okay so this video is a bit overdue but
about a month ago I was in Iceland I
played the Reykjavik open and I recapped
every single game from that tournament
on my YouTube channel playlist is
somewhere linked below but after the
finish of the tournament I immediately
played another tournament that was
broadcast on live Icelandic TV it was
actually really cool I think maybe like
five or ten percent of Iceland was
watching on live TV and in the first
match it was a blitz tournament in the
first match I played none other than
Alexandra botez famous streamer poker
player entrepreneur trash talker as
we're gonna see in this video but um we
did have a camera filming the whole
thing big things to Anna crowling who
snuck a camera in in the playing room so
we have footage of our game and in this
video you're gonna see our first game of
the match now Alexandra will be
uploading our second game of the to her
Channel link will be somewhere probably
below but our first game was very
interesting to say the least and I
should note that I got to the uh the the
playing Hall and I was so flustered
because I had just finished a five hour
game from the Reykjavik open I had less
than like 20 minutes to calm down from
that before I had to play Alexandra and
it was rough um I I was uh you'll see I
was a little bit nervous and I was also
a little bit confused if I was supposed
to like enter and trash talk or just
play seriously so you'll see our kind of
awkward banter in this video but without
further Ado really hope you enjoy the
video want more to say if you like it
subscribe press the like button leave a
comment and enjoy good luck
[Music]
how'd your game go today
it's really long yeah he's fired a
little bit tired no I can tell
the allergy no he did I spent hours
studying the Catalan
um I think I'm supposed to play here
it is still Sherry and is this where I
forget
no it would be really bad if I forget I
think I was supposed to go
home oh yeah this is a line
are we gonna remember it
um I'm gonna take some time here
thank you
all right I actually don't remember my
theory
I feel like you might be blocking me I
could be the poker has been coming in
handy wait so you know what I'm supposed
to be doing here
what
so rude
let's try this
I think you can take here
because I'm playing you I'm talking
quieter than I normally do
I'm not sure
oh I stunned you Hammer will be proud he
really called this a novelty
I wasn't preparing against you but I'm
happy about it
I was hoping you would think
okay you're the higher rated why am I
the one providing the entertainment
could you carry part of the talking Eric
I'm talking to my niece
good one
okay well I'm gonna get in tire pressure
if I don't care I also feel bad trash
talking on other times that's polite
yeah that makes me think I buttered
but at least it's a fun game
if you let me win I'll subscribe
and
uh
foreign
thank you
[Music]
I don't know let's touch River clockwise
sorry
it's not told I assumed it's Street
rules but always the same treatments
not that it'll matter but
good game
yeah